[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
كيف الصحه
طيب بدي ابلش بسؤال
هيك قبل ما نبلش اليوم برايكم وين اكبر
مخزن للطاقه في العالم
في العالم
شمس
دوله احكوا
الصين طب وين اكبر نسبه شباب في العالم
الوطن العربي ينحك الوطن العربي
الجواب هو الوطن العربي الوطن العربي فيه
اكبر نسبه شباب في العالم اكثر من 300
مليون شب وصبيه طبعا اكثر من 60% بالنسبه
سكانه هم شباب
بس شو العلاقه بين الطاقه ومخزون الطاقه
والشباب لو بدنا نعمل هيك حسبه بسيطه بدنا
ندمج موضوع نسبه الشباب بالطاقه لو حكينا
انه اليوم الشباب بشتغلوا 8 ساعات باليوم
انا عم بستنى السلايدات عشان نشوف الارقام
ثمان ساعات باليوم تقريبا 300 مليون شاب
بطلع عنا مليارين و400 مليون ساعه عمل
يوميا
متخيلين بحكوا لك برج خليفه
استغرق عمله 22 مليون ساعه عمل 22 ل 24
خلينا نحكي 24 حكينا احنا باثنين مليار
و400 مليون يعني احنا شبابنا اليوم الوطني
بيقدروا يبنوا 100 برج زي برج خليفه كل
يوم
واذا بدنا نفكر بالترويه الاقتصاديه
والعائله الاقتصادي من هذا الموضوع اليوم
الرقم اكبر بكثير لو نحسب انه الساعه عشره
دولار وبهذا الرقم من 8 ساعات بيطلع عنا
العائد الاقتصادي من بس وقت الشباب في
الوطن العربي 24 مليار دولار يوميا
الرقم هذا بتجاوز اي عائد ممكن ناخذه من
المصادر الطبيعيه ولا من النفط وهذا الرقم
اليوم بميز الوطن العربي بس المشكله انه
في عنا نسبه تانيه خربت كل هاي الارقام
واللي هي انه عنا اكبر نسبه بطاله بين
الشباب في العالم بنسبه اكثر من خمسين
بالميه فاليوم عنا اكثر من 200 مليون شب
كمان عاطل عن العمل وهاي النسبه هي اللي
خلت يمكن الارقام اللي حكيناها يمكن مجرد
ارقام او احلام بس احنا بالوطن العربي
عرفنا نستغل النفس بس هل راح نعرف نستغل
لاهم من النفط واللي هم الشباب
انا سامي حوراني طبيب ورائد اعمال اجتماعي
واب راح نحكي اليوم كيف نقدر نستفيد من
اكبر مخزن للطاقه في العالم
منيح اللي اشتغلت بدي اروح على السلايد
تبع الهرم المقلوب اليوم العالم خلال
العشره سنوات القادمه راح يعيش حاله
ويسموها الهرم المقلوب بمعنى واحنا بنحكي
هون العالم الاول اوروبا وامريكا النسبه
الاكبر من عدد السكان راح يعينها النسبه
الاقل من عدد السكان بمعنى اليوم اقل من
30% باوروبا وامريكا بدهم يعيلوا اكثر من
70% بس هذا هاي النسبه ما رح تكون موجوده
بالعالم العربي شايفين هاي النسبه اللي
فوق هاي الهرم المقلوبه اللي راح يصير في
العالم الاول
بالميه من الناس راح يكون لعلهم اقل من
20% او 70 الى 30 على حسب الاستين ب 250
راح يكون مقلوب بمعنى انه اوروبا وبامريكا
وبالعالم الاول رح يكونوا بحاجه لطاقات
الشباب والوقت والجهد والهرم عنا لسه راح
يكون زي ما هو اكثر من 70% رح يعيلوا ب
30% فعنا فائض كبير مش بس باحتياطاتنا
بالنفط عن نفائض كبير بوقت وطاقات وجهد
الشباب وهذا الشيء اللي ممكن يخلينا نتميز
ونقدر ننهض كامه عربيه اللي عم بيصير
اليوم انه هذا الكلام لا يمكن يصير الا
اذا حلينا ثلاث مشاكل اساسيه للشباب
الاولى هي الاحباط ونقص الثقه بالنفس
الثانيه هي موضوع نقص المهارات بالاخص
مهارات المستقبل والثوره الصناعيه الرابعه
والاخيره قله الفرص وفرص العمل
بدي احكي لكم اكثر على موضوع المهارات
يمكن
نروح اللي بعدها اليوم حتى نكون بامه
عربيه تمتع بالانتاج وبالعمل في عنا مشكله
الشغف اليوم اقل من 10% ل 15% من الناس
اللي بتدرس بتحب اللي بتعمل بشغلها حبه
لدرسته عنا مشكله تانيه بالوصول لفرص
تعليم ذات جوده عنا مشكله بالوصول
للمهارات ومهارات الحياتيه ومهارات
المستقبل الوصول للخبره العمليه واخيرا
مشكله كبيره هي موضوع التحفيز كل هاي
المشاكل للاسف عم بتمنعنا من انه نقدر
ننافس بس اذا تغلبنا عليها وهذا هون
بقوتنا للفرصه اليوم اللي هي الثوره
الصناعيه الرابعه اليوم الثوره الصناعيه
الرابعه
بتوفر لنا نموذج جديد من المهارات عم تحكي
لنا تعالوا اليوم في قفزه بالعالم يتعلموا
مهاراتكس
الفي ار
الاشياء اللي الها دخل بحل المشكلات
التفكير الناقد وغيرها واذا بتتمكنوا منها
بتقدروا تنافسوا وتستفيدوا من هاي الطاقه
في المرحله القادمه وهذا اللي بخلينا
اليوم في حاله انه ممكن يكون عنا تنافسيه
لنقدر نعمل كفاءات عاليه تنافس في
المستقبل يعني اليوم احنا اذا بدنا نفكر
وين طاقتنا ممكن تكون وكيف ممكن تكون بدنا
نفكر بالسوق العالمي كسوق مفتوح نكون فيه
موظفين منافسين او رواد اعمال لكن شو
الوضع الحالي الوضع الحالي انه الشباب لسه
بيعيش بحاله من التعليم السيء
الحاله من الجهل الفقر حاله من انعدام
العداله الاجتماعيه او نقص في العداله
الاجتماعيه حاله انه في ناس اذا اخدت فرصه
بتعليم خاص بتقدر تلاقي فرصه عمل والناس
اللي ما بتاخد ما بتلاقي فرصه عمل وهاي
الدائره المفرغه اللي عم بعيشها العالم
العربي وهذه الدائره المفرغه كانت سبب ليه
انا بدات قصتي في فرصه دوت كوم فرصه دوت
كوم بلش كمدونه قبل 15 عام تقريبا لما كنت
في مقاعد الدراسه بكليه الطب وكاله الفكره
انه اليوم في ناس توصل لفرص تعليميه
وبتوصل لمهارات وبتوصل وبتوصل وبعدها وفي
ناس لا وكان الفكره انه يكون في وصول فليش
ما نستعمل الانترنت لعلى الاقل نحكي للناس
انه في فرص وكان في ايمان انه اليوم فرصه
واحده كافيه لتغير حياه شخص مش بس حياه
شخص وحياه اللي حوله وكثير منا بتذكر
الفرصه الاولى اللي اخذوها واللي كانت اجا
بعدها فرص ثانيه وثالثه وثالثه ورابعه
وفتحت لهم مجالات مختلفه هاي كانت الفكره
بفرصه دوت كوم
فرصه دوت كوم اليوم من خلال الموقع
الالكتروني والموبل الابليكيشن بيوفر
للشباب في المنطقه العربيه وصول للفرص
التعليميه والمهارات المختلفه من خلال
باثوي متكامله او الكاسكيد اللي هو ببلش
من انه شخص يتبع يعرف شو شغفه بعدين ينتقل
ليعرف
يوصل للفرص التعليميه والفرص المهاراتيه
بعدين يروح للخبره العمليه واللي اهم من
هيك يتعرف على الانشطه الا منهجيه وصولا
الى موظف يقدر ينافس في المستقبل او رائد
اعمال فاليوم فرصه دوت كوم من خلال
اوليتها الموضوع الاكتشاف الشغف في اختبار
الشخصيه واللي هو اختبار من ثلاث اختبارات
من خلاله بيقدر الشخص يعرف شو بحب ويطلع
له تقرير عن اهم التخصصات اللي بتناسبه
وايش المهارات اللي عنده وايش المهارات
اللي ناقصته فهذا التقرير نموذج من
التقرير بتشوفوه الثاني
بحكي لكم هلا من الاشياء اللي عملها اليوم
بفرصه اول اشي حكينا تعالوا اشتغلنا على
الاكسس وكان شباب كثير حكوا لنا انه احنا
اليوم فرصه كان زي السلم الاجتماعي الناس
اللي ما كانت الها صارت توصل لفرص وتتعدى
موضوع
الحاله الاقتصاديه هلا عم ندخل بتقييم
لقديش انت قادر انك تنافس في السوق العمل
عم نسميه اليوم هذا بقيم اشياء مختلفه من
هالشغف من هالمهارات وبيحكي لك اليوم انت
70% قادر انك تدخل بالعمل او 80% ممكن
تكون رائقه باعمل وهذا راح تشوفوه قريبا
اليوم بفرصه وهذا بجهد ودعم الشباب بكل
المنطقه العربيه عنا اكثر من اربعه ونص
مليون مستخدم بزياده كل يوم 3000 مستخدم
بوصول لاكثر من 100 الف مستخدم يوميا وعلى
اكثر من ثلاثه مليون من خلال التواصل
الاجتماعي وبنحط اكتر من 150 فرصه في
الوطن العربي
[تصفيق]
هاي المنصه اليوم انا حبيت احكي لكم شويه
ارقام على عدد الزيارات بس كمان على قديش
الناس بتشوفها وهاي مش كانت بشطاره شخص هي
كانت جزء من عمل فريق بس اللي اهم من
العمل الفريق كان هو الحاجه لهذه الفرص
وهذا كان تصديق يمكن لانه فرصه واحده ممكن
تغير حياه شخص او غيره فاليوم اكثر من 40%
بيزورونا بشكل اسبوعي عشرين بالميه بشكل
يومي
تقريبا خلال السنه الماضيه 73 الف
ابليكيشن طلع من خلال فرصه دوت كوم للفرص
المختلفه في المنطقه العربيه وهلا بدي
احكي لكم على نسبه النجاح كانت فيها اكثر
من 23% فاذا بتطلعوا على 23% من 73 الف
احنا بنحكي على تقريبا 25 الف شخص استفاد
من فرص خلال العام الماضي من خلال فرصه
دوت كوم
لما زارتنا جلاله الملكه حكت لها كيف ممكن
نزيد فرص اكثر كيف ممكن الناس تستفيد من
الفرص مش بس نشر الفرص فحكينالها احنا
اليوم عم نشتغل على بناء على حاجه الشباب
على اشي اسمه استشارات فرصه لانه اليوم مش
بس انت تشوف الفرص اللي موجوده وانت تحاول
تاخد خبره اشخاص استفادوا من هاي الفرص او
ناس حابه تتطوع لتساعدك كيف تكتب السي في
او كيف تكتب الابليكيشن تبعت الفرصه او
كيف تعرف شغفك او تكون فكانت هاي فكره
بدايه استشارات فرصه اليوم بتشوفوها الها
اسبوع تقريبا طالع عالموقع لتقدروا تحجزوا
استشارات جزء منها مجانيه وجزء منها
باسعار رمزيه لتقدروا تستفيدوا من الفرص
المشروع القادم اللي راح تشوفوه خلال
شهرين لفرصه هو شو اسمه مسارات فرصه اليوم
بفرصه رح نعمل مسارات الشخص اللي حابب
يكتشف شغفه رح يدخل بمسار متعدد فيه مواد
تعليميه في عمان كورسز فيو استشارات
وغيرها يكون نهايته يعرف
الثاني
للتوظيف نهايه المسار الثاني انه يكون
قابل للتوظيف ونسبته اكثر في التوظيف
والتالت انه يكون ريادي اعمال وهدول
مسارات راح نعلن عنهم خلال ثلاث اشهر من
الان
الاهم من هيك بدي ارجع لموضوع مخزون
الطاقه والشباب اليوم مش طرف انه احنا
اليوم يكون عنا اكبر نسبه شباب بالعالم
ونحكي انه عنا مخزون طاقه بس ما نستفيد
منها اليوم يا بدنا نستفيد من مخزون
الطاقه هذا ونقدر ننمي ونكون جزء من عجله
الانتاج بالوطن العربي ويكون شبابنا قادر
على المنافسه ويكون قادر انه ينافس في سوق
العمل الخارجي والعالمي اما كموظفين
منافسين او كرواد اعمال او بدنا نهاجر
وهذا اللي عم بيصير ويمكن هذا دايما
بيسالوني ليش الطب يعني يمكن كانت مسيره
بالطب استفيد اني
اساهم بمساعده بضعه الاف او عشره الاف او
اكثر من الاشخاص انهم انقذ ارواحهم او
اخفف من معاناتهم بس من خلال مسيره فرصه
ومسيره عمل فرصه يمكن
تهدف وتساهم انها تحاول تقلل من معاناه
مئات الالاف من الشباب انهم يكونوا قادرين
يدخلوا السوق العمل فاليوم وهاي يعني صوره
ابني هاشم بتمنى انه خلال 20 سنه عمره عشر
اشهر من عشرين سنه من الان يكون الوضع في
العالم العربي افضل والمهارات احسن يكون
فعلا اكبر مخزون للطاقه وما يحكي لي بابا
بدي احاجر شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]